o que significa viver sob uma realidade
em colapso ou dito de outra maneira o
que significa viver em um mundo que já
acabou
sim o mundo já acabou não por acaso
nesse momento a gente vive essa
proliferação como o livro de dar nós que
vivemos de castro nos mostram de imagens
do fim do mundo o que significa dizer
que nós vivemos no fim do mundo hoje em
dia significa dizer que nós estamos cada
vez mais conscientes da impossibilidade
do nosso modelo de vida continuar
subsistindo em outros termos nós temos a
mais plena ou deveríamos ter pelo menos
a mais plena consciência de que nós não
podemos estender indefinidamente o nosso
presente em direção ao futuro
basicamente porque o planeta não
suportará a é essa sensação de fim de
mundo é esse mal estar que perpassa as
nossas sociedades contemporâneas aqui de
certa maneira provoca uma sensação de
desconforto inversamente proporcional à
nossa capacidade de imaginar
alternativas à além de uma crise
econômica além de uma crise política
além de das diversas e múltiplas crises
que se costuma trabalhar há acerca do
nosso contexto no século 21 é uma das
principais crises é exatamente a crise
de imaginação a crise
a impossibilidade que nós desenvolvemos
de nos imaginarmos para além do presente
de nos imaginarmos vivendo em outro
mundo mas há muito por vir
um pergunta o livro que eu mencionei é
possivelmente é esse mundo e envolverá
uma variação do presente ele não poderá
ser simplesmente a repetição do que nós
vivemos e então nesse momento eu
proponho é que a gente utilize dois
exemplos duas imagens do que pode vir a
ser o nosso futuro eu vou escolher duas
áreas que são áreas que pensam mais
livremente que digamos assim a filosofia
política
ou essas áreas que custou o jornalismo
cultural
essas áreas que costumam estar mais
fechadas na nossa imagem do presente
dando respostas mais imediatas
então eu escolhi exemplos de um lado da
ficção científica e que hoje em dia vive
uma explosão de obras nas séries livros
há filmes que desenham os cenários do
futuro e do outro lado os estudos de
coloniais e o que eu vou dizer é que é
esses dois campos cada um nos oferece
uma diferente imagem do futuro cada um e
envolve uma variação de um prolongamento
de certas tendências do presente a que
envolvem escolhas e que nos apontam na
direção de algo que transcende o nosso
presente
o que nós sabemos é que o mundo acabou
de alguma maneira nós não poderemos mais
simplesmente ficar paralisados no
momento em que nós estamos situados a
primeira dessas antropologia então vou
chamar de antropologia
enquanto uma espécie de uma imagem da
nossa posição humana a em relação aos
outros entes não humanos
a primeira tecnologia chama de
antropologia estelar na é uma
antropologia que envolve basicamente a
superação do corpo humano
ela envolve o projeto de nós darmos
conta da do nosso futuro é o projeto de
nós transformamos as barreiras do nosso
corpo transformamos a nossa finitude
superarmos a nossa condição mortal
a gente pode observar então isso nessa a
digamos assim brinca ação constante
homem-máquina nessa constante anos com
sede em trincamento na da tecnologia com
a humanidade é uma antropologia do
progresso uma antropologia que envolve
acelerar o tempo e intensificar as
coisas que vêm sendo desenvolvidas
hoje em dia há não só a no imaginário
ficcional hamas também é pelas ciências
né por exemplo apenas deu ciência
néné os cientistas como miguel nicolelis
é vendido vem propondo que ao fim ao
cabo o projeto seria fazer com que o
cérebro sobreviver se a finitude do
corpo humano na lei crucell por exemplo
futurista é propõe é que nós devemos
buscar então o a eclosão da inteligência
artificial para que surge então uma nova
espécie nada singularidade os singulares
danos à então esse imaginário embora vai
evocar a cnaa na ficção científica e
está presente também em projetos reais
em projetos que envolvem inclusive hardy
science
esse projeto então de certa maneira ele
têm em comum
essa idéia de que aquilo que
tradicionalmente na cultura ocidental se
chama de alma vai encontrar um novo
suporte vai conseguir transpor os
limites da mortalidade a filmes com e se
transcendam ans
corra à recente inteligência artificial
apps máquina gata cá
elysium 11 black mirror a série a a
todos todos esses filmes que eles têm em
comum eles são variações do mesmo tema
há exatamente esse tema prometéica da
nossa superação pela via da tecnologia
da mortalidade todos eles contém alguma
versão da ideia de que é possível ou
fazer o upload da mente em outro suporte
ou trocar de corpo ou utilizar
tecnologia ano tecnologia para fazer com
que os corpos possam resistir ao
processo de degradação física ou ainda é
desenvolver um corpo sintético ram ou
não no caso do ex máquina é a dar lugar
a uma nova espécie superior a nós mesmos
na então a todos esses projetos
todas essas imagens são de certa maneira
é a realização profana do que as
religiões do livro
metem na o que essas religiões prometem
a vida eterna a salvação depois da morte
a essas esse projeto essa tecnologia
estelar
ela promete que se vai realizar na terra
esse projeto é pela via da tecnologia
nós vamos conseguir estender nos até o
infinito na da imortalidade
a gente pode observar isso por exemplo
tanto naquele episódio de the black year
chamado sandy unibero quanto é nessa
série nova chamada alter cabo em que os
personagens certa maneira se vêem diante
de um dilema porque na medida em que
eles descobrem que a mente deles pode
ser transposta para outro suporte e
sobrevivem definidamente a própria
questão religiosa entra com uma polia
quer dizer que o sujeito é esse que não
morre mais é portanto não pode ser salvo
na próxima vida então esses personagens
eles vivem um dilema em alta carga por
exemplos as pessoas religiosas elas
assinam um documento afirmando que não
querem trocar de capa né que eles acham
que é como eles chamam o corpo já não
quero trocar de capa porque elas querem
morrer para então poder ser salvas no
outro mundo na em outros termos essa
utopia tecnológica ela é uma exploração
da mais antiga das promessas na que a
promessa da imortalidade da alma
interessante que como efeito reverso
nesta antologia estelar a terra aparece
como um universo devastado na terra
aparece com um hábito desértico natal
como nós vemos por exemplo nesse filme a
estrada em mad max ou ainda jogos
vorazes nação filmes que nos apresentam
uma outra imagem do planeta um planeta
seco um planeta árido um planeta pobre
de vida ao mesmo tempo que apresenta
esse ser é que se coloca acima de todos
os demais na e é conseguem mortalidade
na sua inteligência tecnológica é esse
projeto quando de parado por exemplo com
o problema ecológico ele propõe que
e prometeu moderno ele vai inclusive
desenvolver a capacidade de mexer na
estrutura da terra a por meio da
tecnologia agel engenharia por exemplo é
um dos problemas é a figura que talvez
possa representar e andré wallace aquele
personagem de blade runner é um tanto
quanto cético desiludido desencantado
mas ao mesmo tempo é desejoso de viajar
para as estrelas na uma vez conquistada
a infinitude do corpo
nós podemos então colonizar os demais
astros antropologia alternativa é essa
de certa maneira antagônica é uma
alternativa que eu chamo de antropologia
terrena ela é uma antropologia que
explode de vida o que acontece na terra
ela intensifica a nossa maneira de ver o
planeta
nós podemos por exemplo encontrá-la
entre os chamados povos extra modernos
brasil com a imagem de gaia onde
pachamama a idéia de que a terra também
é um corpo vivo a e que tudo que está na
terra a bunda de vida a nós podemos com
isso diz construir aquela imagem
antropocêntrica do ser humano como fora
da natureza e portanto senhor dela na
natureza como um recurso que nós podemos
recurso energético que nós podemos
utilizar para concretizar o nosso
projeto antropocêntrico essa visão
envolve desvio energizar a relação que o
ser humano estabelece com outros entes
não humanos há como por exemplo o xamã
ea nome davi kopenawa nos apresenta em a
queda do céu na uma floresta com a boa
política uma floresta em que abundam os
mais diferentes seres entre espíritos a
própria florestas minerários animais as
plantas tudo se torna imensamente rico
mas não é só nos povos esta moderna os
que a gente encontra isso dá essa essa
outra tecnologia é uma antropologia do
aleitamento do tempo em que o tempo
desacelera e nós passamos então a viver
a experiência em outra velocidade que
não essa velocidade vazia
acelerada do projeto a estelar da
antropologia estelar
a gente pode traduzir isso por exemplo
na idéia do bem viver que também é uma
ideia oriunda dos povos afro modernos no
caso dos povos ameríndios mas que pode
se traduzir por exemplo numa num certo
estranho retorno dos nossos habitantes
das metrópoles por exemplo no uso da
bicicleta
quer dizer nós temos ali uma tecnologia
muito mais avançada muito mais
confortável como o carro e no entanto as
pessoas voltam a sentir um certo prazer
por a se locomover de uma maneira
corporal
a experiência do tempo a experiência da
passagem não é por exemplo também com a
caminhada com o andar em atividades que
nós daríamos como superadas uma
sociedade totalmente automatizada é
ganha um novo significado na medida em
que elas nos permitem experimentar um
outro tempo uma outra experiência de
vida
uma outra conexão com os entes não
humanos perceber que tudo que acontece
pode ser pode ganhar um significado é
para além do significado banal que se
dirige ao infinito vazio
aaaah os espaços como por exemplo os
passos de devaneio é é um morar bem
o comer bem são coisas que são dadas com
meramente acessórias mas que nesse novo
nessa nova maneira de ver as coisas
ganham um outro sentido nesse tempo
desacelerado nesse tempo relento
alentado em que nós nos comunicamos com
o mundo com a terra há de uma outra
maneira nós conseguimos então
experienciar essas coisas de uma maneira
mais intensa então enquanto a
antropologia estelar
ela é uma topologia intensivista uma em
antropologia colonizatório uma
antropologia que nos remete à exploração
a colonização de outros espaços
a idéia de que tudo que nós temos é
pouco e nós precisamos sempre crescer
crescer crescer é o infinito
a crescer até o ponto em que viajamos
para fora do nosso próprio habitat a fim
de encontrar um sentido oculto é elevar
a nossa própria maneira de ser para
outros lugares
a antropologia terrena por outro lado é
uma tecnologia intensa uma antropologia
da intensidade uma tecnologia que
envolve pesar o nosso ser na terra a que
envolve intensificar a nossa experiência
anterior ao que envolve fluir a de uma
outra maneira as experiências dadas como
banais mas que na realidade são aquilo
que nos tornam repleto uma experiência
em outros termos de suficiência é uma
experiência de quem é considera que é
nós não necessariamente precisamos sugar
toda a energia pra realizar o nosso
projeto mas podemos viver
suficientemente e muito bem com aquilo
que temos
então é isso obrigado
[Aplausos]